you had this habit that was getting you
into a little bit of trouble well hello
you were you were taking you you take
ambien and you were tweeting you were
tweeting while on ambien oh and I'm
curious have you managed to put a stop
to that Andy don't judge me that way
it's incredible bravery well yes I've
had some troubles and I love ambien I
don't do drugs I don't advocate but a me
and does help me sleep because of the
time zones and you travel a lot I also
point out you give the kind of
performances where you're giving
everything you got and then it's hard to
come down you understand yeah so yeah so
all night II I'll have like a chicken
wing and a pop-tart I'll wake up on that
eating oh it's me and grace and a hot
tamale you do that thing where you go
into Lake people say they go into this
sort of trance state and they do things
they have no memory of my mother told me
that in Texas a woman woke up on ambien
ordering a car at a car dealership
anyway but yeah I picked a boy fight
with the boyfriend I haven't dated in
five years while you were on ambien so
walk me through this did you go to his
house yeah yeah I let him have it I was
like this is what I think you bla bla I
was onto you you were texting him
texting and he brought me back is I
haven't spoken to you in five years this
is why yeah so you have no memory of
being young or anything I also like I
was watching 20/20 and that a whole
thing about honeymooners going on a
cruise line and one came back and won
didn't you know murder yeah I love this
is the universal sign for cruise ship
murder
[Laughter]
by the way I'm not auditioning for Bambi
just you cannot be in that band yeah but
yeah so eating Oh anyway the the cruise
line I'm at the fairy godmother of a
quantum of the Seas very probably so of
Royal Caribbean but on 2020 baked did
this whole thing about cruising and you
won't come back alive
so I tweet hey don't wanna cruise you
might not come back alive the next day
we're equivalent calls like Hello
you're a spokesperson for them I made
soup I planted a bomb on a roommate I
said quit cooking in the night she goes
girl that's on me that happens yeah take
ambien with precaution ladies enjoy take
it was precaution yeah about the person
you're dating maybe don't go on a cruise
you know or just take some ambien